die kanzlerin hat gerade eindringlich
davor gewarnt dass wir in einigen
großstädten nicht in allen aber co2
einer situation stehen wo man die
kontrolle verlieren könnte wo wir ins
exponentielle wachstum kommen sie sind
mediziner und regierungschef was läuft
schief in den großstädten was muss jetzt
passieren worauf hat man sich geeinigt
na ja wir können jetzt nicht einzelnen
großstädten vorwerfen dass die pandemie
dass das virus sich eben dort verbreitet
wo die menschen eng nebeneinander
miteinander leben das sind eben die
großen metropolen
die enger es ist wie hier in berlin wie
bei uns in hamburg umso schwieriger wird
es auch die virus ausbreitung
einzuschränken
deswegen sind jetzt gerade die
metropolen aufgefordert mehr zu tun als
das was in den flächenländern nötig ist
und insofern war es gut dass wir heute
diese konferenz hatten um erfahrungen
auszutauschen und auch eine gemeinsame
verabredungen zu treffen wie wir weiter
vorgehen und wie sieht diese wie sieht
das aus was passiert jetzt konkret in
hamburg und in anderen deutschen
großstädten was bisher nicht passiert
ist wir werden die erkenntnisse die es
gibt zum beispiel aus münchen wie man am
besten hohe instanzen wieder zurück
führt jetzt konsequenz überall weiter
verfolgen das ist eine fortsetzung
dessen was wir schon begonnen haben
allerdings eben unter schwierigeren
bedingungen der kalten jahreszeit mit
größerem nachdruck und das bedeutet dass
wir eben dort wo infektionen auftreten
bei privaten feiern in der gastronomie
überall dort wo alkohol im spiel ist
dass wir dort noch strenger werden in
den beschränkungen und auch stärker
kontrollieren
denn das sind die erfolgsrezepte dass
man dort ansetzt wo infektion
tatsächlich entstehen aber dass man
verbote und regeln kontrollieren muss
ist jetzt keine neue erfahrung warum
erst jetzt und warum hat man sich jetzt
erst zusammen telefoniert
das ist jetzt eine konferenz gibt es
einen vorschlag der bundeskanzlerin den
ich sehr begrüßt habe ich hatte mit ihr
darüber gesprochen und ich glaube es ist
sehr gut deswegen jetzt von der
landesebene in diesen metropolen
diskussionen gehen
es ist auch nicht so dass wir jetzt
bisher etwas falsch gemacht hätten
sondern wir haben einfach schwierigere
bedingungen jetzt in der kalten
jahreszeit ziehen die menschen sich
stärker aus dem freien wieder in die
innenräume zurück und dann kommt es eben
zu
zu schwierigeren infektions
rahmenbedingungen und deswegen ist es
jetzt genau der richtige zeitpunkt um zu
sagen
die regeln sind wirksam wir müssen sie
jetzt konsequenter noch ein halten und
deswegen glaube ich ist der richtige
zeitpunkt für eine solche konferenz aber
auch für das öffentliche bewusstsein
aller bürgerinnen und bürger das ist
jetzt auf sie ankommt und dass der
gemeinsame erfolg in deutschland nur
möglich ist wenn alle mitziehen wir sind
bild und wir liefert dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier und vergesst bitte nicht unseren
kanal zu abonnieren